hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's what i in a day review is
sponsored by buildbar
and we will be looking at another
harper's bazaar food diaries video from
american supermodel ashley graham but
before i get into it i want to chat
about my sponsor
build bar now as you know i don't
normally eat a lot of protein bars
because
if i'm being honest i think most of them
kind of taste like crap
but as a busy breastfeeding mama i am
all
about quick easy handheld snacks so i
was
really pleasantly surprised when i tried
one of these
they taste legit like a marshmallow
coated in chocolate
so good i would eat them even if they
didn't have any protein in them
so today's flavor is going to be
apple almond crisp this one has 18 grams
of protein
let's take a little tasty
so good and because this is a lower
sugar bar
i would pair this with a piece of fruit
or toast as a post-workout snack for
muscle repair
but these have been awesome as like
breastfeeding fuel in the middle of the
night
my hubby definitely approves because
most of my snacks like cereal and nuts
are
super crunchy and just like obnoxious in
the middle of the night
anyway all the flavors i've tried so far
are super yummy and i'm so excited to
make my way through the rest of this box
with you guys so
if you want to try them out i will leave
a link below for 20
off of your order also you can pause the
screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning for those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
a reminder that this format follows a
celebrity's description of what they eat
and tells me very little about its
accuracy portions
brands cooking preparation etc not to
mention their overall relationship with
food
so take this more as general education
to the masses
not as specific recommendations to
ashley
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on a future episode
all right let's see what she has to say
around six o'clock i hear
and i go and i get isaac and then we
come back to bed and we have snuggles
and i feed him in bed
we basically have the same morning
routine baby alarm clocks
not always super reliable on you know
what time they're gonna go off
but i promise you you'll never sleep
through it well
unless you're my husband let's see what
else she has to say i am
a high high high caffeine coffee drinker
three to four cups a day do not judge me
do not come for me in the comments
it is my life i drink about a gallon of
water a day to you know
counteract all the caffeine so girl i
will
not judge you on that i get that between
work and motherhood life is
exhausting so you drink that coffee if
it brings you
life and joy and as i always say i don't
critique
people on their coffee order but before
you comment warriors get anxious over
here about breastfeeding and
caffeinating let me break this down
with science so when adults consume
caffeine
the average half-life or the time it
takes for the caffeine level to
decrease to half its starting dose is
about five
hours in newborns it's almost four days
now if that sounds super scary it's
important to remind yourself that
you're not hopefully putting a latte in
a bottle and feeding
that to a baby the mom is drinking it
it's then being metabolized and
according to the american
academy of pediatrics less than one
percent of that caffeine
gets into the milk now while the
standard 200 to 300 milligrams
recommendation that we're given during
pregnancy
doesn't typically seem to cause any
issues
research does show that caffeine
consumption exceeding
300 milligrams per day can increase the
likelihood of an infant showing symptoms
of caffeine stimulation
like fussiness irritability or under
sleeping
every baby and adults caffeine tolerance
is of course unique
and tends to increase as they get a
little bit older
so if ashley's little one isn't affected
by her three to four cups of coffee
which
is probably between 300 and 400
milligrams of caffeine per day
then great i am not here to shame
every mama has to know their babies best
but if you're breastfeeding and still
want to enjoy your morning joe
know that the research suggests that
when caffeine consumption is kept within
the recommended guidelines
the amount that can be passed onto the
infant through breast milk
is negligible and generally regarded as
safe as for the water i'm glad that
she's focusing on
hydrating since fluid needs are
significantly
higher for breastfeeding moms it's not
that the water helps to
flush out the caffeine like she alluded
to
but since coffee is a diuretic it may
help replenish any of those extra fluids
that are lost
let's see what she's going to be eating
i am a big breakfast eater
also i'm breastfeeding and like we have
to take in so many calories when we're
breastfeeding so i feel like a
bottomless pit
at all times usually i make scrambled
eggs and that's also what isaac eats as
well i spray a little bit of coconut oil
on it
and i take two eggs put some oat milk in
season it with a little himalayan sea
salt i can attest to the bottomless pit
feeling
there are days i could legit eat all day
and still
not feel full you just ate
but those eggs do sound really good
right now for like a quick hit
of saturating protein and fat i do just
want to flag again
that as i've said before you know that
pink
fancy himalayan sea salt while delicious
and slightly higher in trace minerals
like calcium iron potassium and
magnesium
it's not that much healthier than
regular table salt
you would have to consume a lot of it to
get any substantial quantities of those
nutrients
so i just say choose a salt that you can
afford
and that you like and focus on getting
your minerals from more plentiful
sources
like fruits and vegetables recently i
cut gluten out
game changer if you are tired and your
joints hurt just cut out gluten for a
couple of days
i saw the difference immediately okay so
let's clear this one up here folks one
it's absolutely true that there's a link
between celiac which is an autoimmune
response to gluten
and other autoimmune disorders like
rheumatoid arthritis and diabetes
in fact according to the celiac disease
foundation there's between a 1.5 and 6.5
chance of developing arthritis if you
have celiac
as for non-celiac wheat sensitivity
while less
is known about the relationship a lot of
people do complain about symptoms like
joint pain and fatigue now one study
found that 29
of patients with non-celiac wheat
sensitivity
developed an autoimmune condition
compared to 21
of those with celiac and 4 of those with
ibs
and it is possible that this might not
just be related to the gluten
but also to the fodmaps or other
components of wheat
so it's important to work with a
dietitian to get to the root cause
of your digestive issues or your other
symptoms like feeling fatigued
or having joint issues i like to put a
little bit of dairy-free butter
on my toast i kind of go a little bit
ham
because in my head i'm like it's not
real butter it's dairy-free butter and
then i put my eggs on top and i eat it
like an open-faced sandwich
ah yes the classic
dairy-free health halo
it's kind of like how some packages of
licorice have fat-free on the label
which
i assume is supposed to make people
think that it's healthier
but at least the girl acknowledges that
this is kind of faulty logic
it's ultimately still fat and
arguably less healthy than actual butter
the gluten-free bread on the other hand
is generally
less nutritious than its gluten-filled
counterpart since whole grains
generally have more fiber less sugar
and more healthy fats that said there's
absolutely nothing wrong with a little
bread
and butter or non-dairy butter with your
eggs
in fact i love that this meal supplies
some solid protein
carbs and fats and is super easy to put
together
and eat while you got a baby on the boob
all i would love to see is maybe a
little fruit or veg i'll probably be
making my second cup of coffee
and depending on if i want to have a
juice i love the brand
natalies it's like this perfect like
little bit of tartness
that's my morning breakfast and then i
can get my day started
love me some grapefruit juice and coffee
though obviously not together because
there is no food combination more
triggering
than that but i also don't count juice
as an ideal source of fruit in my books
yes it helps apply a healthy dose of
vitamin c which is great
especially this time of year but you
would be missing out on a lot of the
fiber in whole fruit or veg
so if you're like me and you feel like
segmenting a grapefruit is
painfully unrealistic because it is
a few handheld clementines or an apple
or a banana would also do the trick
my favorite bone broth is from this
place in new york called broto
it is show yummy maybe have someone
order me a gluten-free cookie
probably have another coffee peanut m ms
specifically peanut m ms
and avocado with sea salt and a little
bit of olive oil i love anything
uber wet cold and crunchy definitely an
eclectic collection of snacks
right here bone broth we've covered
extensively
in my kylie jenner review but i will say
that while an acquired taste it is a
good low calorie source of protein with
about 10 grams of protein
per cup the gluten-free cookies again
still cookies despite what a lot of
marketing campaigns will try to tell you
um but since she's also a fan of the
peanut m ms which are
obviously the best m m's i don't really
get the sense that she's obsessed with
clean snacks it sounds like gluten may
be
a legitimate trigger for some unpleasant
symptoms for her
so she's finding some ways to satisfy
her food cravings
that don't aggravate those symptoms as
for the avocado and cucumber
can i just say like i love how she
described these snacks
you can tell that these are just
straight up pleasure for ashley
they're not pulled from a list of
must-eat diet foods
avocado with sea salt and olive oil
sounds incredibly
luxurious and delicious and particularly
delicious sounding when paired with that
crunchy
cold cucumber when you can think about
naturally nourishing foods like this
rather than foods that you need to eat
because they are healthy
or clean you are so much more
likely to want to eat them when i was
pregnant i thought that i was going to
be craving like
mac and cheese fried chicken but i just
needed like a bagel
sweet green salad sometimes two for
lunch when i was pregnant i usually like
to have a romaine
lettuce parmesan chips with an avocado
chicken carrots cucumber a honey mustard
or like a spicy chipotle dressing
so it's really funny because when i was
pregnant with
baby e all i wanted to do was eat salad
like
drenched in a really acidic vinaigrette
probably because i was dehydrated and i
also couldn't stomach a lot of like
protein
or cooked foods with strong smells so
salad
and fruit especially really acidic ones
was really all that i wanted so
girl i get you i feel like the term food
cravings has been hijacked by diet
culture to mean
junk food but if you're listening to
your body it doesn't have to be it could
be really
naturally nourishing food as for the
meal itself
it sounds amazing and totally my kind of
salad order
we've got fat and the avocado cheese and
dressing protein in the chicken
and lots of fiber-rich veg we could
totally add in
like a gluten-free carb here like quinoa
or rice
but if she felt satisfied from like the
peanut m ms or the cookie snacks
then i'd say it all balances itself out
i do just want a flag that i noticed
ashley mentions that she was eating for
two while pregnant
and now only for one and i actually want
to
semi-debunk this so first of all
caloric needs don't actually double in
pregnancy
though i get that it can feel like they
must
but even in the third trimester you're
only looking at an
extra 350 to 500 calories
that's literally like a coffee shop
muffin meanwhile depending on your
breast milk supply
most nursing or pumping moms are
expending an extra 500 calories or
more per day so in reality your needs
postpartum for milk production
and recovery are potentially much
greater than they were when you were
growing
that babe inside you let's see what
she's having for dinner usually i'm
having dinner around
6 pm my friends called the early word
special or
granny's delight but also i just feel
better when i eat early and then that
way
later if i'm gonna have like a little
snack i can have something light but i
don't feel like i'm heavy when i go to
bed
love me a granny delight come on if
you're not even eligible for the early
bird special at ihop
are you even momming
but no even though talking about feeling
heavy
when you go to bed sounds kind of like a
diet culture statement
i do get what she's trying to say here i
think a lot of people find that they
have a hard time digesting a big meal
and then just like laying down for bed i
know that i
have found that having like a geriatric
hour meal and then
going for like a slow walk on the
treadmill or outside after dinner
definitely helps with my digestion and
quality of sleep
and ashley and i are not alone but we
had
lamb stew every night and it is
unbelievable lamb purple potatoes whole
garlic
and then he puts it in the oven it's
super delicious super filling and
especially after you have a baby they
say to eat lots of like
really hot nutritional food oh man
i am here for the hearty postpartum
stews
i made a huge batch of like a dozen
different soups and stews before baby o
came so that i had lots of warm
hydrating meals ready to go and i'm just
now coming to the end of my stash sadly
i want some more but i love that the
stew has the protein from the lamb
carbs and the potatoes and i assume
there's like some tomatoes or some other
kind of veg in there
but a stew is also an awesome place to
sneak in a lot of
random leftover pieces of vegetables
that you have in the fridge
so if it was my pot of deliciousness i
would probably throw in some diced
zucchini
some bell peppers and maybe like some
frozen spinach
he'll make this thing called general
chicken because it's literally just
general chicken on the stove top with
garlic salt and pepper
okay i don't know who needs to hear this
probably not my vegan followers
but i just want to say that i think the
best chicken recipes
are the simplest chicken recipes my
hubby tells everyone that i make the
best chicken breast and it's true
i do but really you just want to season
it really well and
not overcook it as far as i'm concerned
those are the only
secrets you need to know on thursday
nights justin and i do date night
because you know
to have a happy marriage you do day
nights
i will treat myself to two tequilas two
margaritas oh
margarita i knew i liked this girl ugh i
haven't had a good margarita in almost
two years because i've either been
pregnant cooped up inside during a
pandemic or
both but it's definitely up there in
my top 20 cocktails
wait a minute what i like a lot of
drinks
now as for the elephant in the room can
you drink
and breastfeed well this is a
complicated and
slightly controversial topic but in
short
you do not need to pump and dump
after hitting the bottle puffing and
dumping doesn't speed up the elimination
of alcohol from the milk
and the amount that finds its way into
breast milk is also
relatively low according to the american
academy of pediatrics section on
breastfeeding
alcoholic beverages should be limited to
no more than
.5 grams of alcohol per kilogram of body
weight
which for a 60 kilogram mother is
approximately
two ounces of liquor eight ounces of
wine or two beers
it's also important to note that alcohol
levels in breast milk peak around
30 to 60 minutes after consumption and
as your blood alcohol level returns to
normal
so too does your milk so most
authorities suggest that if you're sober
enough to drive
you're sober enough to breastfeed
according to the godfather of
breastfeeding
dr newman the biggest risk of drinking
and breastfeeding
is that you might get so drunk you fall
asleep with the baby
or you drop the baby that said this is
not
i repeat not an endorsement to drink
while breastfeeding
i'm just stating the little research and
recommendations that we do have around
this
you have to do what you feel comfortable
with and if that is complete
abstinence then that's great for you too
but i like ashley enjoy a well-timed
drinky drink after the babies
go to bed let's see what else she's
eating we go to alamar usually which is
my favorite local restaurant in dumbo
and i always get the bronzino fillet
with a side of broccoli
and i start with the endive salad i'm
not gonna lie
i do order it out like probably three
times a week
it's amazing that does sound like a
killer meal again there's no harm in
adding like a carb side dish
but if you prefer your carbs in
liquefied grape form
or dessert then i guess that works in my
books
as well so for a restaurant meal this
sounds both delicious
and really nutrient dense so big thumbs
up from me
my favorite food city has to be calabria
italy so my absolute favorite thing to
eat
is the cannolis now i invented my own
way of eating the cannoli for breakfast
and i was putting it on
watermelon call me crazy but it was
like a miracle of explosions in my mouth
i just want to know what all my italian
friends
think about this combo
i mean i get pretty excited about unique
food combinations
like i'm not a purist by any means and
i'm trying to envision it i am trying to
imagine it
and i'm not gonna yuck someone's yum
here because my goodness
she is selling it i honestly i would eat
anything
if it was described first by ashley
graham but my culinary intuition tells
me that
the watermelon would just like sog up
the crisp cookie shell it would be like
dunking a biscotti in
fruity herbal tea instead of coffee that
would just be
such an injustice also i do hope that
she's able to tolerate
some gluten in her diet because i feel
like all the best
pastries and pasta in italy are probably
not gluten free
i have some me time
so that's usually when i'll either pull
out my frozen dark
chocolate out of my freezer because i
think that dark chocolate frozen is the
best
and one of my favorite things to eat is
sliced
apples drizzled with peanut butter on
top
okay so the way i read these interviews
often comes down to
language intention and attitude and
these late night snacks could come
across as super restrictive
as it did when like kelly ripa talked
about her
treats being like a single chocolate
almond
but it really comes down to the context
of one's day and also how they
view that snack ashley talks about these
foods with
absolute enthusiasm and gusto like she
really makes it a sensory experience
just to hear her describe them and while
dark chocolate may be the stereotypical
healthy treat and wellness culture
ashley doesn't seem to discriminate
against classic like 7-eleven special
peanut m
m so it's clear to me that the girl just
probably eats
what she likes and isn't judging herself
for it so
these sound like awesome bedtime snacks
to me
all in i'm loving that i'm seeing a lot
of variety in ashley's diet
with the exception of some potential
restrictions around gluten
and dairy which she may have her own
health reasons for
i don't think that her diet is
particularly restrictive in any way
i mean she puts battery spread on her
bread and eats potatoes in her stew
and knows her way around a bag of cheap
candy
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today a big thank you again
to buildbar for sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below with any other
youtubers or celebrities whose diet you
want me to review
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
good